welcome to the women in public policy
program seminar series podcast at the
Harvard Kennedy School
hi we go ahead and get started I'm ya
know Riley ball time the research
director here at the women in public
policy program where we are committed to
closing gender gaps and Economic
Opportunity political participation
health and education and the honor of
introducing our seminar speakers and
we're very excited today to have Pienaar
Fletcher who is a doctoral candidate in
organizational behavior here at Harvard
she is going to talk about competing at
all costs dysfunctional competition and
gender I had an opportunity to read a
draft of this paper it's really terrific
and I'm sure we have a lot to talk about
p nagas works collaborates closely with
a number of Wow affiliates and I think
I'll just leave it there or if we're
just very excited to hear your work and
have you hear something today our
research this is a research project that
I contacted with mine
kolhapur caffeine again naturally who's
here she's also at Harvard Business
School they looked at gender differences
in what we call the destructive
competitive behavior we contacted a
series of lab experiments and I'm going
to talk about those lab experiments but
before I get into that I want to talk a
little bit about what motivated this
research theory because of research show
that as I'm sure many of you in this
room know that women are severely
underrepresented at the top of
organizations of according to recent
endless research women make up about
only fifteen percent of about top
executives hi Ernest and fortune 500
companies
and the researchers have been trying to
explain this gender gap for some time
now so one of one stream of research
that's also based in the field of
behavioral economics of the contact a
bunch of lab experiments look at this
issue and what they did was in a lab
experiment they asked men are among
truth between a competitor winner winner
takes all type of incentive scheme also
known as the tournament I work incentive
scheme that was obviously competitive
and non-competitive piece rates in the
winner-takes-all competition with price
was higher so just you know I don't know
putting some numbers to illustrate what
I mean people were choosing between a
winner-takes-all type of competitive in
town six intact incentive scheme but
potentially four dollars per output
versus working on their piece
where they would earn just two dollars
per out but but obviously if they lost
if they don't score as well as their
puppets there's an intertextual scheme
in santo scheme they would burn nothing
so been overwhelming the majority of the
man with the higher paying competitive
owner takes all incentive scheme and the
overwhelming majority of women wanted
the non-compete their floor came
peacefully so based on these findings
researchers argued that the gender gap
that I've showed you here might be
called not necessarily why and
demand-side explanations such as
discrimination but the supply side of
explanations such as such as women's and
men's or gender differences in
references meaning women not our honor
examples in these jobs because they're
not applying for these of high-paying
topical better job in the first place
you probably can't tell from my wife
step I'm such a huge fan of that
explanation so so like to wrap up this
research is saying and showing that man
as higher propensity to compete dominant
and stop second research as i mentioned
basically problem advised the most or
propensity to compete and focused on in
search of that but which is interesting
because the same student of research
also shows up a significant chunk of man
by choosing to compete they're actually
losing money they're leaving money on
the table by preferring the competitive
schemes over the non-competitive
because these are men who are performing
badly so as a result found a true the
competitive scheme they lose and they
are nothing whereas they would have been
better off with a straight scheme are
they with you know like furniture
low-rate look things actually you know
at least get something for their efforts
so basically men are actually not always
been everything for their higher
propensity to compete
in general we know from research on
competitive preferences individuals
general both men and women to benefit
from showing proof that the behavior
they need to evaluate their competitive
environment carefully and judiciously
make the benefits of competing against
positive beginning and that make a
decision so you know going back to the
example that we talked about before they
apply for competitive high-paying jobs
both men and women then you took around
first of all they need to decide what
their qualifications are who their
competitors are and how they make new
friends I give managers if just being
competitive reflexively without and
applying for jobs that you might not be
qualified for or getting yourself
compared side-by-side with somebody who
is who has like much superior
performance or experience value is not
necessarily going to help you in fact it
might perk you rather than help you
yeah we know little about monogamous
relative able to j to evaluate the
contents of context we w tours gauging
its benefits making this costs this is
because most research that look that's
either point at the behavioral java
differences improve at the behavior they
either focused on types of competitive
behavior that confirmed that covert pure
benefits and no costs to the instigator
not such as certain types of sabotage
behavior where the only the person that
you're trying to pop your competitor is
there an awesome you're just feeding
benefits or they looked at a competitive
context where there was no variation in
terms of expected benefits and costs of
display
in particular research focused on the
winner takes all type of competitive
competitions where participants received
no information on their performance on
how they are ranked against their
so no performanc back in North okay so
in our research shall we try to address
this by do two things one we looked at
the type of competitive behavior that
was very explicitly associated with full
benefits and costs that distracted me
that the behavior which we define us
complete the behavior that means the
hurt the competitor or the competitors
but has the potential for net losses or
netbeans meters so it's a type of
competitive behavior where you're trying
to avert the competitor but by doing so
you're running the risk of was actually
hurting yourself as well
and we also look at the variety of
competitive context that vary in terms
of expected benefits and costs of just
playing competitive behavior and that's
a quick it would with like a chicken
game fall into destructive competitive
area is that that how that's been
conceptualized yeah chicken game or you
know I don't know you're destroying your
colleagues work but yeah thnkx battle
look actually getting caught fire hook
for example
um I mean the idea was to like I'm just
any more like more on terms of economic
models that people might choose from I
was just thinking like so like the
chicken game where you in essence
veering toward one another and if one
doesn't give out they uh you know I
guess like here the competitive behavior
is only coming from north of the
behavior that aims to hurt the other
content there is only coming from one
side okay okay so you know it's
unidirectional yeah and it's just so
it's really sabotage is it is the
essence of what your focus primarily on
yeah it's a professionally with residual
cough like behavior that that has the
potential to hurt the saboteur it's
tough the risky risky sabotages
unidirectional risky sounds just trying
to understand exactly what you're doing
so as I mentioned our aim in doing all
of this was to figure out our gender
differences in ability to evaluate the
competitive contexts and the minimum and
differ in their ability to gauge
benefits
of displaying this particular type of
effect on behavior in doing so we were
trying to figure out what their men and
women can't distinguish between context
for displaying competitive behaviors
sort of more dysfunctional from those
contexts where the same
rational or beneficial
foundation so
via looked at three factors research
organizations are typically used and
these three tools to the signal and to
set the expected benefits and costs of
displaying permits to be here they use
different type of incentive schemes they
use different types of performance
feedback schemes systems and number
three they use behavioral norms or
establish behavioral persons to signal
the benefits and costs of the behavior
of within organizations
the primarily focused on two types of
competition contexts high intensity and
low intensity high intensity
competitions use winner takes all
incentive schemes with high social
comparison or highly comparative
performance feedback
a typical example of a winner-takes-all
type of incentive scheme would be a
Employee of the Month award or some type
of promotion systems where the top four
performer the top performance get
everything recognized the so-called
losers they get nothing for their
efforts especially under a typical
example of a high social comparison are
highly competitive performance feedback
system is a 360 degree review here of a
focal individuals performances
explicitly and infinitely compared to
those of others here both the incentive
scheme and the performance feedback
system emphasize recognize and reward
only performance relative to others
individuals get the signal that their
own individual performance is only
important
in relation to have their personal
in contrast in low intensity
competitions variable reward schemes on
no social comparison or non comparative
performance feedback systems are English
under the variable so here still a
competitive environment but individuals
feel that their individual
accomplishments in birth and performance
still matter regardless of how they're
ranked against others so for example in
a variable award scheme of the top
performance performance did get
recognized and that they would burn at a
higher rate or they would you know get
more for their efforts but everybody
else would still be getting paid or
boarded by in line with their
performance a typical example of a
reward scheme would be like a bonus for
profit sharing the two factors you have
have to go together the high that winner
takes all with high comparison or
variable with Logan there's and I'm
thinking about you know making partner
or making tender where at the end
there's certainly
a winner-take-all but along the way
there's not necessarily high social
comparison yeah so we are essentially
focused on these two competitive
contacts and they don't look bad
yourself again yeah they don't have to
go together but you can see that how
they can actually go together in terms
of analyzing performance relative to
others so what we did must be this was
our initial focus on different
combinations so so I guess back to low
intensity competitions and what I mean
by non-impaired to know social
comparison performance feedback systems
so here an individual will get argues or
get feedback in relation to how key or
she did overtime or relative to a more
objective defined performance platinum
are such and such as an organization
personal phone
so
to clarify that a little bit further
let's say and there's a sales
organization on this salesperson the
salesperson what he told you solve X
this year versus you sold why last year
whereas in the high social comparison
performs feedback the same person he
told you hold X this year whereas you're
here or your peers why
um
so in high-intensity competitions
individuals get strong clear cues that
winning and eating their competitors
doing better than their competitors is
everything as a result expected benefits
of the hour
the start of a career and trying to trip
up your competitor has a relatively high
expected benefits and secondly it has a
relatively
more expected costs the benefits and
costs are also
because of the incentive scheme and
because of the high social comparison
performance to be fabulous you know
where you stand
in contrast in low intensity
competitions you're getting more week
and because signals as to
the appropriateness or ultimate ii of
engaging and such strong people based on
behavior
for example in sound scheme policy about
bidding is good but even if you don't do
better than others that's okay as long
as you maximize your own potential
because you're still getting paid
inflation to your performance so here
are expected benefits of very general
expected net payoffs of engaging
destructive who fits the behavior are
relatively low and on cert
so given that expected net payoffs of
engaging in distracted competitor
commits the behavior much are
significantly higher in high in hospital
conditions and only intensity
competitions be predicted that such
behavior would be late observe such
behavior a lot more often to a higher
degree to a significantly higher degree
in high-intensity competitions involving
national competitions however we are
predicted that this relationship between
gender and competition intensity would
factor actually be qualified or would be
moderated by the gender of the focal
individual who is making the decision
and this part
explain how bird how do you think about
this interaction effect of help
in detail next
so so small situations are strong what I
mean by that is that in strong
situations people get a clear
unambiguous citric now accuse that about
the optimal or appropriate kind of
behavior meaning people know or they get
very strong cues that behaving a certain
way is going to maximize their
individual pales in these kind of
situations these strong situational
effects of dominate people's behavior in
your room for individual differences
such as gender-based differences so in
these kind of strong situations both men
and women taking their cues from the
situation they be
and as a result you usually do not
observe any kind of significant general
different gender-based differences in
behavior
in contrast unique situations to get
damages and mixed signals about how to
behave and what is likely to optimize
their individual outcomes but
situational cues are being a mix like
this it leaves room for gender-based
differences to treatment so in these
kind of situations both men are moment
they start listening and behaving more
according to John the base prescriptions
so what do these gender-based
prescriptions tell us format these
gender-based norms dictate that man acts
on
competitively and assertively achoo
orienta
in contrast these same gender
differences tell us about women should
be mindful oh there's mindful of others
interests other oriented whom you know
more
so because of this in these situations
many lemons
heber start diverging and we see
significant gender differences
um
my favorite research that shows us if
I'd actually is research going back to
why and on my quarter kathleen megan
with the Babcock there they looked at
gender differences in negotiation
performance and now they found that when
there was no ambiguity about life issues
can equal to the negotiation table or
negotiating with appropriate at all men
and women behaved equally assertively
any purpose equally well but when there
was ambiguity about what camp negotiated
than women start going back and think
how I acted sort of any negotiations and
as the results and not started man the
better forums negotiations that moment
competitive negotiations so obviously in
our case competition in that intensity
is a strong situate it is a source to
situational cute
high intensity competitions are strong
situations here expected tales of
displaying destructive repetitive
behavior are relatively high uncertain
also men element will also get clear
strong signal skills that they should
behave competitively engage in
destructive movement to the behavior to
maximize their individual chaos so we
expect attractions like this in glowing
Tassadar competitions of the situations
worse here individuals are getting mixed
signals about the appropriateness or
optimality of engaging and destructive
moment
expect pals from such behavior but
expect ales from the striker competition
are relatively low and uncertain so here
we expect man so in general in
competitive environments there isn't a
conflict between gender-based norms for
math competition
are expected to behave effectively and
assertively and be agent oriented so we
expect a man to continue to show
reflexive of the behavior in these tough
environments where as we expect we
predict women to take a step back and
give elite competition context more
consciously and start about paying
attention to
John debase norms which think they
thought they should be other oriented
communal and fair so we expect to see a
jungler difference here
so this formally translates into
significant interaction effect between
gender competition sound intensity such
that you know mean tacit equal
conditions man would show a higher
capacity for distracted w
and women there will be women in high
intensity or conditions will show a
significantly higher propensity for
destructive competition than
to put this phone
interaction different plain English we
expect the of them and to change their
behavior in response to the changes in
with the environment whereas
up to show a similar
as our Russian of behavioral norms are
another value later behavior we're about
to start the convent
verifying organizations they just like
incentive schemes and performance
feedback systems they signal and
expected benefits and costs of
such behavior as destructive event
indicator so for example an employee
sees that her boss engaging and
destructive behavior shoot you more
likely to inflate that x behavior
thinking oh you know this is
wardha this
organization but we know from past
research that looked at these behavioral
norms they come to the effect that well
made
situations and low-intensity own
condition
so we also looked at how behavior norms
affected this type of destructive
competition individuals the start of
behavior and we also looked at
how these behavioral norms I think the
gender gap in behavior we saw earlier
for we are pretty
and the
so given that this is a big situation I
think we predicted up there we still eat
differences in how men and women
reactive Lisa k remarks
again formally very long time City
compositions they're pretty thing that
herro norms or presidents established by
others would be M latest file observers
of meaningful
such behavior
the norms will take me such behavior
but again given that this is a situation
low intensity competition we expect
men have them and the people respond
the behavior large tub correspond to
their bodies make
so this is a road map of our studies in
the study one instead to be examined the
effect of competition intensity and a 33
the isolated loading competitions and
look at how behavior norms affect men
in those situations
so in our lab experiments via paired
participants for the Pampas
how the constant it was the same person
is a real person it was a person
well in the past
some participants specifically that
person was performing
wats down information about average
because we want to give for partisan
sales commissions a reason
engaging in the starting position we
gave partisans this somewhat annoying
task for people that have to task gave
them these
around them alphanumeric code and they
were supposed to look at us see these
clothes on the screen and type
as they can because they were operating
on the time pressure
they
they were given a practice round of this
task before they started on the label
don't okay grounds
so in study 1 we had that two-by-two
between-subjects design on participants
were male and female participants were
assigned either to a high in faceting
competition audition or low intensity
for solution for mission in
high-intensity competition winner takes
all incentive scheme was used along with
high social comparison
feedback under the winner takes all
incentive scheme participants learned
that in each round they would burn three
cents per capture that they transcribed
provided that they score higher than
their counterpart and under the high
social comparison feedback system at the
end of each round they learned what
their score was not round and their
competitors were in contrast in low
intensity they could take up pick on
their variable or scheme and they
learned that again they were going to
get three cents for capture transcribe
transcribed if they scored better than
their counterpart but if they didn't
they were going to still get two cents
per captcha transcribed
under the no social comparison feedback
system at gana peace corps they learned
their occurrence of score and background
and what they did in the previous round
so here we were giving them essentially
information on how they perform the
first time we try to
focused on trying to put their own best
so it's not complete no social
comparison right because they know if
they get three cents they know that they
did better than their competitor so they
don't learn what they have earned awful
the very end of experiments OIC so but
but but so then kisses you guys but
these guys are every round or some
things in your life I'm sorry these guys
every round they find out or something
like how often are these guys getting
the social comparison information in the
Hajj Marshall comcast yeah at the end of
each round so thank you okay these guys
just do multiple rounds not knowing
anything exact I see the person they
were competing against is not always the
same person I was at sometimes man
sometimes me know so it was the same
person was a real person
and we gave that the information
completely
gender neutral place and the a sparkles
most people
behavior but
Oh
so this was the the flow of the study s
1 comment on this question the
low social comparison treatment was
getting it was paralleled information
every round it was just information
about their own performance alone the
other was getting information about the
other sites for father's you don't
actually know these captions sort of how
did the doing as you go along so it
wasn't like they were just sitting there
getting no information that we're just
getting feedback another
notnot payment just feedback just
feedback on their own organs yeah yeah
so they do just tell like you did so
many and then they don't know whether
they got two or three cents until the
end yeah yeah I thought that's where I
got confused and clip they were getting
near 36 thank you were getting there
three cents then they would know yeah
yeah hi intestinal audiences so as you
say they're both getting information
about who they're competing and for now
I gotta both getting information about
like four they're competing against you
say that so everything knew that they
were competing against somebody like it
in a pool of something they could really
are they just know that this in person
participating the same study on the same
conditions but already on the same
instructions bubble so many structures
on the same set of rules okay
so this was a floor of the experiment
participants complete the practice round
round one round two and then just before
they started round three they were asked
to make a decision essentially so this
was our main dependent variable where we
studied the propensity for destructive
competition essentially what they could
deduct up to 16 points from their
competitors next round score but if they
do so they lost points from their own
score up to five points and higher point
deductions were more closely so the one
extreme they could deduct up to 16
points from participants next door but
then they would lose five points from
their own score and at the other end of
the extreme they can choose not to
engage in the star communication and
also they don't deduct any points on the
other person's next score and they don't
lose anything from
so these were the people are findings
we're looking here at the points that
participants chose to deduct from the
other person just before they started
performing in that round
as you can see as we predict the humans
behavior did not seem to change across
different competition structures whereas
women
womens women show the second floor
propensity for distracted competition in
low in town
high intensity which created the
significant gender difference RBC
competitions
next we looked at the actual net payoffs
the net profits or losses the
participants were able to weep from this
point deductions from engaging and
destructive competition so
so obviously people are
making more money in high thousand
competitions that
but there's a significant interaction
effect between competition and gender
women
women's essentially the moon's pale
because there are behavior is responsive
to what's going on in the structure in
the competition structure they are
burning more they're beating more
benefits from what deductions from
engaging in historical condition
explain how the
saboteur I'm trying to like
understandable first and like the
technical sense how when they engage in
this that under what conditions does
that benefit you and then and then
secondly like I'm trying to like
relieved as you go along to like what
these examples might look like if like
working the world so like Hannah's
example of like sabotage like that idea
something catches EV lose but like what
would this type of situation look like
so yeah thank you for reminding me
talk about that so so i guess i'll talk
about some extreme examples
we'll make a little more sense of you
know bomb partisans get the profit
versus a loss so at one extreme if you
are
work if you're on the working if you're
in a complete high competition intensity
condition and you're working on the
and you deduct points
you win
and you
because
you are making
engaging
so I guess and
the real world let's say
I know that's
she wears like it
they're expected to
prepare a proposal
and you know that the person actually
creates the defending solution for
client they're going to get a promotion
so
you prepare it undone you know like your
main competitor chief will get there you
know repairs on
just before the day of presentation you
go here
or numbers or something or you just like
completely destroyed believe whatever
for presentation because of that you get
the promotion and she loses out so
you lose points to write in the game
right yeah so and do so you do lose
points but
but you would have made 0 anyway
situation so essentially the post is
zero
so the real world example
you work off
fire because
how analogous it really is because if I
was playing a game and put like hard to
strategy the game was to deduct points
from other people that wouldn't be like
an ethical question for me I would just
be like oh I'm planning this game where
is like just deleting my competitors
presentation would be this huge like
there's no way evidence that are doing
that so to me in the game I can totally
see my something like what's that a
strategy here i'm playing a game so now
cos early you know this is abstract show
you know experiment that's why I've been
treating my horse they're carefully and
I actually did not use the courts of
Etosha for like a sabotage my behavior
because apart because
because it's almost like you know kind
of like a llama
so to think maybe another analogy would
be going negative in a campaign so
winner-takes-all campaign doing negative
campaigning negative campaigning is
risky to me because it's not that
positively perceived but I get to hurt
the other thing that might be maybe
that's a stronger real-life analogy yeah
can you go back though to your just the
slide right before this like why are the
women doing better in high-intensity if
there's no gender difference in behavior
and high intensity so the second
experiment will explain why Oh Graham
you know just to give you a preview is
because they're paying attention to
where the Iraq against their cool
pictures of men are just not paying any
attention okay okay so so what do you
see okay so that you are a gamer
sabotaging devices were sabotage
whenever we use for exactly you manage
us yeah just looks like subway
it'd be fascinating I have a propensity
at all why they should be fascinating to
actually look at the two further to go
back one slide 54 lost hand side to see
the frequency distributions of the
impact of the sabotage rules
to just get a slightly better feel for
this yes yeah
so wrap up the final sorry well whatever
and so this has benefits read from
destructive competition so is this only
incorporating the data points where the
person who did engage in the yeah so so
how we calculated at this what I should
have actually said the night before
sources so this is a bonus
that participant additional ones
partisans are able to meet from district
competition lines any bonus that they
fall down because they deducted points
from the other person so if you have not
engaged in any point deductions in space
of a 0-0 0 so they're a bunch of zeroes
about fifty percent up to people
don't engage to their life
if the personal justice
so just to wrap up these findings it
seems like women there they're more
attuned to what's going on in the
environment they're more attuned to the
competition quantized structure as a
result they're changing their behavior
significantly
whereas men they seem to be a me
a month reflexively and showing a
similar propensity for a distraction
effective behavior and gross competition
conditions
because of that
women are weeping more net benefits
were more net payoffs from engaging in
such behavior than men
so you study to go factor question we
separated the incentive scheme
performance feedback system separately
so what that end up what we ended up it
was a two by two by two between subjects
design so but the
the instructions study procedures
weren't exactly the same otherwise so
here participants male and female parts
participants they were assigned either
to a variable more scheme more minutes
foamy Santos scheme and separately they
were run as I needed to a high social
progress or
persecution
and these are
the results of point deductions or the
minimum is propensity for the starter
content behavior so you see men are
divorced and as you can see this
remarkable consistency across conditions
for his movements is the grayness like
as a downward stepwise function I you
know if they again they're replicating
findings from our first study at people
that's actually how these two of our
study you just look at these two extreme
cases and you're replicating these
findings no gender differences here in
high-intensity
see
close by the
see change their behavior their
responsiveness +1 on the context whereas
change here
and again I looked at the net
office or losses payoffs that part ships
participants were able to leap from
these point deductions from the starting
position again we calculated the same
way bonus edition any additional bonus
part systems were able to get minus any
bonus that they give up because they
chose to deduct points so
insides of scheme social comparison
order for problems feedback John Theurer
they all mattered they all had a
significant main effect one on the net
pay off sweet but there was a but all of
these these main effects were qualified
by one as significant to a interaction
between gender social comparison
availability of social comparison and a
marginally significant through the
interaction between all of these three
factors and the two-way interaction in
gender incentive scheme so putting that
in English what we find is that women
are sings can play more able than or
more competent in factoring in social
comparison information into their
decision-making before they engage
destructive competition
but that in fact is qualified by the
three-way interaction so essentially
women are particularly adapted doing so
factoring the social comparison
information on where they stand against
their competitors in under
winner-takes-all incentive schemes or
putting that differently man seemed to
appear to factor in the type of
incentive scheme that they're working
under to some extent although net as
effectively as women but they are
factoring it they're not factoring the
social comparison information the
information on their computers at all
they make their decision just a little
bit about your population are all those
women and then the same or how did you
sample your
so these first two studies were
conducted on amazon's mechanical
platform after know if you're familiar
with that so they're basically like a
American population they were all adults
between the ages of 18 15 and 65 with an
average age of about priority that's
pretty much all i know from well this
experiment but there are people who
contacted research on who these people
are and they tend to be pretty
representative in terms of like where
they live etc they actually tend to be
like fairly well-educated obviously very
confident computer literate people they
most of them they tend to have at this
song college education
but they come to be a low-income America
solo not all going on but like a little
too averaging I'm saying these things
coming studies on Mechanical Turk they
don't pay that much you're essentially
getting paid I think like
so seven dollars per hour so
be willing to good job
page basically yourself or differences
within the group of man and the group
differences I don't
thank you fine oh oh oh I see they're
like age I I didn't look at that at all
yeah i know and i guess like one more
thing they come to be white no but we're
bombing white so our next study did
actually at Harvard's lab
so
so um
as I mentioned another tool that
organizations used to regulate this kind
of behavior
looks like an even type of the behavior
is through establishing camera presence
or
as I mentioned past research shows that
they can be effective in the moment a
city officials in each situation so
that's what we looked at as a reminder
we expected
presidents to be hated by observers and
expected to find gender differences
given the situation lately
so in this study we took male and female
participants and they were randomly
assigned to one of the three
determinations so this is essentially a
22 by trade in subjects designed so the
null behavior normal conditions
essential for cultural foundation and
this is
exactly the same same condition as in
the low intensity competition commission
in the previous two studies
so this is what we're doing different
here here participants manathil kiddo
behavioral or omission participants
beaudesert another participant somebody
need designated as a leader refrain
refrain from the strength coefficient
this person was given an option to
engage in point deductions but this
person chose not to engage in
destructive competition or point
deductions the competitive hero norm
condition at their words happened
participants thought that the
participant was given an option to
engage in destructive competition and
they did so to the fullest extent they
deducted
so this was the flow of the experiment
again they did seem task practice round
round one and then just before round two
we asked them to make a decision about
point deductions again exactly the same
way using the same options so here you
measure their baseline propensity for
destructive competition and then they
point lead around too and then they were
assigned to one of the three DeHaven on
conditions if they were done in the
movie paranormal control condition they
just you know content on experiment but
if they were in one of the competitive
or non-competitive behavioral conditions
they made that observation about the
other person's behavior and then they
were given the decision to engage or not
engage in point deductions before
running 30
so this is our main area of interest
here we want to see how their behavior
changed from the baseline that's after
pitaj they observing behavior alarm I
thing on one condition that they were
assigned
so
this is the main high-quality alarm
capacity for they start the competition
so this here is our patrol condition is
being predicted of those participants
who hopes are the
non-competitive behavioral norm
see if you can to decrease their
capacity for distracted competition
ultrafire predictions compete compete on
behavioral norms did not have a
significant effect on people's
procrastinate for the stratification
does this person's significant but this
so next as you remember me and predicted
that men and women would be influenced
differently based on
because of because Johnny prescriptions
different so this is what we city here
I guess before I get into this
I should say that's a bum so this will
be
before evils of behavioral norms this
accession replicated Harvey sauce men
were significantly more likely than
women to engage in destructive
competition so now we're looking at how
that changed
so comparing
the cultural foundation
feminine nah effective behavioral
condition we see a significant decrease
I'm comparing man control condition
demanding the competitive behavior on
condition busy a significant difference
in behavior
so just as we predicted the
who are only responsive to the nonprofit
than behavioral norms and then they're
only a significant they're responsive to
compare the behavioral norms and as you
can see just this is control condition
the gap actually decreases
behavior
in round three men are if they do not
observe any behavioral norm at all men
are actually decreasing their programs
day love
a little bit but the gender gap is still
very significant despite this portion
did you experiment with making with
these norms
that's like explicitly gender & like
saying you know women don't really
compete so yeah or like so yeah I wish
we had done anything like that we just
talked about the other person in general
terms here I'm just that
I don't even like
you have the cities like the math tests
and stuff where they tell girls
beforehand like girls are really good at
this task is it actually sounds like you
are like so I wondered if you like gave
exclusively gendered cubes about yeah
interesting so what we find about how
people think about gender without
there we find that
they actually say the gender of the
other person at all and so the rest 20
so those we assume something there
the other person's male and
church
interest in the linguistics so that's it
really like a little white in
I
um
but the interesting thing is
despite the defects
think of their competitors
I don't know but yeah so it doesn't of
interesting
yeah I was just wondering nobody
air-conditioned
you're sort of stuff
yeah but I think so that is not the
significant difference
but either format known for women but I
think if you kept on doing that but i
think or
start
so it seems like at these two times in
quick succession it doesn't
Jessica but that doesn't mean that
she won't enough but i have to say that
I would be careful about that because I
mean I want to study that I don't know
what the answer is but you need to be
able to careful about the conclusion too
because how often are you exactly in
situations the world so it's situation
with all the different
emotional reactions
go back to cities one and two I think
your enormous result and women do better
like a sabotager on the left hand side
we did that work with work with just
male and female Harvard undergraduates
um
I know you don't know the answer but
yeah I don't know the answer but I know
that I did the same experiments and
low-intensity competition commission
only on its words so so what are you
something I need to feel it so wondered
whether this is the sabotage result or
women are dramatically more sensitive
here for more effective and identifying
how we behave in mixed removal contents
and if it's a ladder and the reach of
the reason asked by Harvard is to do a
better job of controlling for other
variable so so on em Turk gender put
correlate with lots of different things
if you only have Harvard undergraduates
and you control for most of these things
and so they do something kind of
fascinating about this
women to the environment that they're
Mia yeah so that's the question we're
not answering you are saying
conclusion we're drawing is that women
are more sensitive to the competitive
environment or it could be that they're
just more sensitive to their social
environment in general not but but what
you have here on the left-hand side is
is an enormous result for the
superiority of women in a profit making
contacts based on their social
sensitivity I don't think that I've ever
seen that in any environment and the
question is whether that that
generalizes the lots of other tasks
where you need to wear the behavior of
the other side might be predictable
based on the past where women would pay
attention to that and men would lose
that and I'm thinking about them so you
know about you know what the
Brandenburger have this book on
cooperation which is all about
identifying when you need to cooperate
with your dependents yeah and sort of
that whole class of real-world
environments and a large number of games
and people think I'm good women do a
better job if you gave them some
information about yeah that's a very
interesting question like it somewhat
related research that actually that's
not published
from long business school what they
actually do that in their study is
they
did something bad
two men and women like they get the
essential customer by somebody and
in
the game and done dating down to very
cooperative game and women were actually
a lot less likely to mention that to
forget like what happened so I don't
think I mean that's you know like just
very preliminary research so I don't
think it you know expense these results
will
I know
situations but I'm so neither the
investor ones research they show that
the research that motivated all of the
station had both men and women
they make bad decisions before they
enter into
the games man they just act to author /
confidently
bad performance on days money that way
and on module women they are under
confidently on tables money because of
that so I don't think it these results
cannot be like generalize to everything
I don't know yeah
I think there's other I think even if
you go back to like the old like Ruben
and brown maybe this they look at least
they did all these um kind of like you
know genders personality studies and
actually women that the results are very
similar to what you described you know
with women not men men actually changing
their play in games with you know
cooperative potential and women not you
know like persisting in retaliation
after after defection and stuff like
that so I mean it so you don't and you
also actually the results on gender and
integrative problem-solving don't really
favor women necessarily there's not
there's certainly no evidence of women
being better if anything some people
would like to argue men or better based
on the results so the pattern to exactly
to your point I'm just adding a little
bit more grist to your argument doesn't
oh well what about on whatever like a
shot and Freud effect for men or good
like a schadenfreude uh frankly got him
you know like the Charlotte foreign shot
ed Boyden winning yeah joy is somebody
else or chain oh you know we're like the
video game effect or something like that
you know like do that one thing I wonder
is so you look at these things of the
men are making a trade off like let's
let's assume they're somewhat rational
like maybe they get such a kick out of
this game where they bust the other guy
yeah they don't even care what they win
they're like I will pay you a dollar to
just bust on this guy for 10 miles you
know how healthy the data but I'm going
to talk about yeah okay no but it's
gonna guess that's not the case so good
yeah but I'm
let's give you have more stuff you
shouldn't show us or we don't want it we
can bugger at the end keep going
so what we did in all of these goodies
at the very end of the study we asked
partner we asked participants of why
they chose to the doctor or not deduct
any points without any front so then we
went and looked at those
we called them some common themes
emerged so for deducting points people
found for the documents those who
actually stark choices lock points
very war by majority nine ninety five
percent April studies
pretty consistent across studies in two
different populations they used a
utilitarian pragmatic self-serving five
of justification like you know like I
thought I would you know like this much
this much so i mounted it just like
like just
not very surprisingly you're a lot more
likely to come across an explanation
like this in high intensity competitions
than a moment athletic competitions and
the very interesting thing here is that
we find the significant gender
difference but there is no gender
difference in high-intensity
competitions that janna difference merge
is only in low intensity meaning women
are probably realizing this no one who
makes pragmatic sense
I'm not sure why maybe they're just
thinking like oh I'm you know we should
be fair it's a nasty thing to do or
because they're like oh hold on a second
it just doesn't make no longer make
sense
it won't create a profit
I'm looking at the payoffs it seems like
they are thinking about pants
can't really decide that
so another five percent of them claimed
that they deducted points because of
some sort of like letter directed it's
tragic reasoning something along the
lines of like oh i deducted points
because i thought the other person look
at that point so i was like trying to
contract that
so for not deducting points
so these are the people that could not
think into destructive competition the
leaving explanation was a concern for
fairness
or a lot more likely to national
sorrowful Karen's done men especially in
low intensity competitions so I think
the parallel thing is happening there as
well rather done you know making a very
fragmented calculation some of them are
just saying
when because maybe they're also just
like reflexive when it no longer makes
sense about the situation if X are not
not dominant may be rather than thinking
very rationally about that they might
just be pulling back because I hold on
there so I'm not sure so the the next
people mashup rational people mentioned
which are the very high overlap that the
first category was a concern for the
other
this was like typically national
like oh you know like I wanted to repair
don't they tackle the census like I
don't know what to do that person
another person and then the third
explanation which is I think pretty
interesting is like a utilitarian
pragmatic reason for not engaging in
distracted competition so this was about
twenty five percent of the participant
so this is like oh i thought i was going
to win anyway or I was winning anyway so
why would I engage in
I think so we're a lot more likely done
man
to say something along these lines
and so does lasting pertains only to the
last any of your friend the behavioral
norms about people observe some what was
our competitive behavioral norms these
gentlemen differences between men and
women about the concern for parents
concern for the other they disappear
I just want a question propagation maybe
i missed the explain so i missed this
but they're playing against the same
person all the time and then they see
how they did but today today which out
today they deduct points from the other
side but is it like it is that the point
reduction are they do they presume
that's invisible liked it or like in the
end the other side because the other
side never reduces points right so that
so they don't that be so they're kind of
doing point reductions blindly without
knowing whether the other side is
reducing points on them and the other
side never reduces points on them yeah
yeah he left them just at mia's
further studies are not but it does seem
like
people are really like
paying up that much passion to the you
know like what happens next with the
other person it's only a five percent of
the people who
you know even prompt them specifically
about like Oh what do you think that you
know like other person was going to do
how the diffracted your decisions upon
profit only what five percent of the
people wrote them into
decision
so I already talked about this a little
bit it seemed like most people to issue
anything about the gender of their
counterparts
those who assume something
then I seem to have any effect
so
too I guess
I mean cab all of our findings we're
finding that woman's
the behaviors
market instructor just a touch me I PS
right yo and as a result they adjust
their behavior and because they adjust
their behavior in response to what goes
on in the
at the moment they need more benefits
from their behavior them so discography
no goes back to how I open up the
discussion man do not always benefit
from their less selective and higher
propensity to compete
we also think that our results of my
might shed some light into seemingly
contradictory findings in the literature
so passage searcher found that past
research found that women they do not
like to compete they shy away from
competitive environments but they can be
very competitive with each other the
point of blocking or sabotaging each
other isms so
so we think that actually there is
research by rogue analysis shows that
this kind of these type of behavior
sabotaging each other women
be kind to happen a male-dominated lot
of organizations so we think that what
might be going on but Mars is that they
might feel like they're in
low-intensity competition there
numerous male colleagues and in a
high-intensity competition there
their view and more salient female
police winner takes all
comparison to be the 12 done
so as a result ironically they might be
more likely to engagements of a posh
like behavior towards their mail please
and that would actually ironically exist
we rate though the gender gap in these
organizations fashion
and finally I guess more generally these
results we'll see then show some money
tons negative effects of some
motivational tools the organization's
couple games such as 36
for promotion policies to a certain
extent seems like organizations might be
better off with structuring their
internalization competitions as low
they also need to keep in mind that that
might actually
create the gender gap
so I'm actually nice
things already so
questions
we live a minute so once you just want
to kind of wrap up with your so this is
something I already mentioned max asked
his question so he saw that man's
behavior was not responsive to changes
in the competition a market but so we
conclude that and are not responsive to
the changes in the competitive
environment but we didn't compare their
behavior between a competitive and
non-competitive situation it might be
that they're just not paying that much
attention to their social context in
general so we don't know if it's the
competitive context works or social
context in general that they're not
pay attention to
and finally we also just you know looked
at the ratio
the prizes and winner-takes-all and
reward schemes was a constant ratio
across all studies so as I resolved and
expect the payoffs
from
the scheme was Scott was constant so
we're kind of generalizing results based
on that but it might be interesting to
shrink or expand up expected payoffs
between different
situations and see you know like maybe
if through the gap you know gets wider
you might see more sensitivity in kv r
so on so forth so it's sort of like you
run against a civilian up on these
results of people
I guess finally there are some other
managerial tools that can be used in the
real world to counter this kind of
behavior we just use behavioral norms
but obviously organizations they can
allow baseless punishments or doors for
behavior so
you might be able to get different
results
they're such explicit stronger materials
thank you thank you um but night next
week please join us Deborah roadies a
professor of law at Stanford University
is going to talk on the big question of
what women want I hear about that